okay so there's one point I want to add
on money which I think is very important
for people to understand which is I
think one common
incorrect way that people conceptualize
money
is they think of it as if it is a finite
resource
so imagine I had like a pile of firewood
okay and then I burned the firewood bit
by bit over the course of a month and
there's no firewood left and then
there's no fire but we need to go get
some more firewood people think about
money as if it's like that because from
the perspective of an individual it kind
of is like that if you spend all your
money then money money Runs Out but
and then for example during covid the
government spent a lot of money so then
this is kind of perceptional the
government spent a lot of money we've
run out of firewood we all need to be
poor now there's nothing we can do but
money always is up to zero always is up
to zero money
from the perspective of society cannot
run up
it can only pass from person to person
it can only be held so